so you've been in the room with Putin
um let me ask you for some advice
and it's also just a good philosophical
question for you or for me if I have a
conversation with Vladimir Putin right
now can you advise then what questions
topics ideas to talk through to him as a
leader to him as a human what would you
like to understand about his mind about
his thinking
yeah remember what I said before the
Putin always tries to you know reverse
things he wants to hear the questions
that that people have
because remember
he himself at different points has been
a recruiter which is you know the way
that you're operating now as well right
you're asking an awful lot of questions
your questions also betray you know
often at times where you're thinking
about things you know the kind of
context
um
you know kind of any kind of dialogue
like this reveals a lot about the you
know the other person yeah and I've
actually often you know noticed in these
settings that Putin likes to have a lot
of give and take so I think he would
actually enjoy having a conversation you
know with you but again he would always
be trying to
influence you inform and influence
that's kind of you know part of the way
that he always operates
so what you would have to you know be
trying to think about so what is it that
you would want to elicit information
from him you're trying to understand the
guy's worldview and what we're trying to
also understand is if there's any room
there where he might compromise on
something
you know so if your goal was to go in
there you know to talk about Ukraine at
this particular moment
I mean one of the problems that I've
often seen in the sort of the meetings
we've had with people it just ends up in
sort of mutual recriminations
you know kind of know well what about
what you've done or no you've done that
about you know and um there's always
this what about it I mean it often said
well your thing that I've done this but
you've done that the United States
invaded Iraq what's the difference
between you know what I'm doing and all
of the things that you've been doing
here
I mean what you would have to try to do
is kind of elicit information about why
or what he is thinking about this
particular moment in time and why he
thinks it
yeah the what about USM is a is a
failure case I think that shows
from all the interviews I've seen that
with him that just shows that he doesn't
trust the person on the other side no he
doesn't right but I I I'm not cynical
like people's they they seem to think
he's some kind of KGB agent that doesn't
trust anybody I disagree I think
everybody's human
and from my perspective I'm worried
about
what I've seen is I think whether it's
covid whether it's
uh
are there aspects that I'm not aware of
leading up to the invasion he seems to
be less willing to have um charismatic
back and forth dialogue yeah an open
discussion you know actually you know I
said you asked me before about you know
that
of
themselves
full of people but he just trusts some
people for certain things where he knows
it's within their competence
so
he has people he trusts to do things
because you know he knows they'll do
them and he knows that they'll do them
well which is why you know he has his
you know old buddies from you know Saint
Peter's book because he's known them for
a very long time and he knows that they
want you know try to pull a fast one
over him but he also knows their
strengths and their weaknesses and what
they can be trusted to do I mean he's
learning that you know some of the
people in the military but he you know
thought were competent or people on
other things are not right that they're
eating tends to actually have a lot of
loyalty to people as well or he also
kind of thinks it's best to keep him
inside the tent than outside and he
moves them around you know he kind of
okay you know he gives them multiple
chances to redeem themselves if they
don't it's not like he hasn't done in I
mean yeah there is a lot of that in the
system but the people that he's worked
with for a long time you know he moves
them around to something else perhaps
where they can do less harm although you
know we've often see that he he has
quite a small Cadre of people that he's
reliant on and but you know they're not
up to the task which is kind of what's
Happening Here but he also in the past
has been more straightforward just like
you were saying here more pragmatic
and I think you know if you were engaged
with him in Russian while you're
actually literally speaking the same
language because there's so much Lost in
Translation I used to jump outside of my
skin listening to some of the phone
calls because you know the way that
they're kind of relayed you know with an
interpreter oh because you listen to the
translation no because I know I'm
listening to the Russian and the
translation you know in real time I know
I haven't been here to translators
Institute it's pretty difficult look an
interpret is a trend in the moment to do
something you know the synchronous the
the Synchro the synchronized or the
real-time translation
it's a translation is an art as well as
a skill
if you're doing simultaneous translation
that's the word in English you know
synchronous in Russian you're you're
kind of focused in the moment on the
fragments of of the discussion trying to
render it as accurately as you possibly
can
and when you come out of that you you
can't relay the entire conversation
and often you know what translators do
is they you know they take this little
short handle like journalists do and
afterwards you know they they've just
been caught up in the moment and they
haven't got the big picture
consecutive translation is different you
know kind of you're trying to convey the
whole mood of like big chunks of of
dialogue that have already been there
but you know sometimes you might not get
that right either and it breaks up the
flow of the discussion that's terrible
and and often it's you know the kind of
the person who translates it's different
you know some of our best translators
are women
but you know hearing a woman's voice
translating a guy who has a particular
guys with speaking and a matcha way of
speaking and a crude way of speaking
it'll be that Putin or I've seen that
happen with uh erdogan the president of
Turkey you know and it gets translated
by a much more refined you know female
speaker you've just lost the whole thing
and you know many of the translators on
the Russian side are not competent in
English in the way that you would hope
they are they're not it's not just that
they're not native speakers they're just
not trained to the same high standards
they used to be in the past yes and you
just get you lose the new ones you use
the you use the feel you know you almost
need you know kind of the interpretive
actor you know doing you know the kind
of the uh the interpretations like you
need to match it as much as you can in
the way that you you know do voiceovers
and film the best way to talk to Putin
is one on one
in his own language I want to have a
really great friend um here who is one
of the best interpreters of Putin is
often Us by the you know the media
um to interpret for him which is just a
he was at the Institute that I was I
mean I know him from that kind of period
and he is just excellent just like Pavel
plushinka was absolutely phenomenal
interpreting Gorbachev now he didn't
always interpret him accurately because
Gorbachev made lots of grammatical gaffs
and sometimes was you know Gorbachev
himself would joke that palashinko you
know spoke better for Gorbachev than
Gorbachev could himself but Putin is
actually quite precise and careful in
the word that he speaks because there's
a lot of Menace sometimes the things
deliberately other times there's lots of
humor and he's telling a joke for a
particular reason and all of it is I
mean he actually uses the richness of
the Russian language and the crudity of
language that can't be conveyed official
Expressions yeah facial expressions body
language the word that he sits back in
the chair and slouches the the kind of
the way that he makes fun of people and
he you know kind of uses irony just some
of it's just lost and it needs to be
conveyed it the depth of humor and wit
I've met quite a few like political
leaders like that in the speak only
Russian when I was traveling Ukraine
um
I I don't know how you translate that I
think it's almost uh the other person
that reminds me like that a little bit
is Obama
there's Obama had a wit and an
intelligence but like uh he would Smile
as he said something that add a lot to
it like uh like that he's trolling you
or he's being sarcastic or like I don't
it's me converting it to words it's
obvious that all English speakers if
they listen to Obama but if you had to
translate to a different language I
think you're going to lose a lot of that
yeah I mean when I watched um the I mean
I watched many of people speak just you
know just in Russian not looking at any
of the you know the subtitles or
anything and it's just watching the word
that is body language is at the at the
time when he's saying things the whether
you smoke he'll sneer he'll laugh he'll
he'll ad-lib you know kind of from
something that obviously kind of you
know wasn't there on the prepared uh
Speech and it's really critical and you
know kind of a lot some people speak you
know like trump it just needs kind of
just
words
Putin the words are very important
Trumpets the atmosphere it's the the
kind of the way you feel about things
it's the buzz you get you know it's
revving people up it's the kind of
slogans and Putin is you know peace
conveying a lot and what he's saying
that I think I mean of course I don't
know much because I always speak Russian
and English but I have in English or
Russian have not met
almost anyone ever
as interesting in conversation as Putin
the I think he shines not in speeches
but in interactions with others yeah
when you watch those interviews and
things with him and I've you know been
at many of these sessions it's been
hours of him parrying questions and it's
like watching um a boxer sparring you
know the kind of training bout yeah come
on give me another one you know and it's
kind of like and he Prides himself and
and he's made mistakes
often but the the breadth of you know
the issues that he's often covered has
been interested has been fascinating and
I used to just take you know kind of
really detailed notes about this because
you learn a term but it's not about his
worldview again
I mean he does live in a certain box
like we all do
and you know again his World experience
is not as extensive as you know you
would hope it would be but that's why
you have to really pay attention that's
where we've messed up
that's where we haven't really paid a
lot of attention to what he's been
saying he's been telegraphing
this
grievances dissatisfaction this I'm
gonna do something for years
and the thing is during war time
the combined with propaganda and the
narratives
of resentment and grievance that you dig
in on those like
maybe you start out not believing it but
you're sure it's all going to believe it
eventually well you convince yourself of
the time yeah look the longer
you're in a position like Putin 22 years
now coming on 23 years it could be out
there for 36 years
you become more and more rigid I mean
this is again you know something that
you see in history you know you look at
you know people through history have
moved from kind of being kind of
left-wing and you know in a um
perspective to hard right they kind of
have a kind of a sort of an ossification
or a rigidity emerges in their views I
mean again I used to have these
arguments with Professor price Bob
Lennon because he would talk about
Vanessa but he didn't change his mind
from being 18. have you not thought
about that I mean it's like we're not
formed fully formed in individuals at
our team you know we don't know anything
we know something but not everything I
mean and obviously the younger context
you know the kind of the way that you
kind of grow up the place you grow up
the things that happen to you the
traumas you have I mean all of these
have an impact but then if you don't
grow beyond all of that and Putin's been
stuck in place since 2000 when it became
president he's not out and about you
know kind of being a man of the people
and I you know he's not doing the kind
of things he used to do yeah he gets out
there and he goes to Kazakhstan and you
know got him Tajikistan and he goes to
China and he does this nothing and
Jacoby he didn't go anywhere I mean very
few places and so he got he's got stuck
and I that worries me a lot because you
could see before that he you know had a
bit more of flexibility of thought
and that's why nobody should be in
players forever you should always kind
of like get out there and go out there
and learn a new skill you know kind of
you need some he needs to sort of you
know he needed to get out more and do
something different